and now he is being admittedly I mean on
one side is talking about prophet Moses
um he doesn't understand that Prophet
Muhammad Allah is Allah then he came how
many walls did he participate in how
many people did he kill by his sworn he
doesn't even know that historically the
sword of Methuselah it killed only one
enemy can you imagine that how many was
really participated in how many people
were killed a lot of wars that took
place at the time of Prophet Mohammad
Suleman I have a background to it yeah
and those backgrounds I'm not very sure
this guy has never studied toc-toc rook
before we go to break someone might say
what do you mean just one one you said
that only one person was killed by his
sword yes elaborate on this I mean see
if a battle is solved and if he's the
person was too interested to be violent
and kill enemies he should have killed
hundreds of them thousands of them but
then you find that only one person is
killed through his own that means he is
not a warlord
but everyone testifies about prophet
Moses LOM a lot justifies in the Quran
even for ambience for number twenty one
has the more insulin ba ma arsalnaka
illa rahmatan lil al-amin we did not
send you but as a mercy to the entire
universe and mercy is that the people
who are innocent should be given mercy
and forgiveness and the people who are
criminals shall be dealt with justice so
now if some criminal is being dealt with
justice that is not being of our Lord if
American national security is defended
by attacking the enemies of America by
going for war with the enemies of
America you are not going to call that
Americans are more laws you're going to
say they're defending the national
security and if it is done in the just
cause then it's a just war yeah so that
is how the history of Islam goes with
Prophet Muhammad SAW club his words were
just Wars and look at the teachings you
studied Polamalu G the subject in which
you study about wars and you come to
understand that there are different
categories of wars and all the world
that the purpose of monism fought but
just was just worse yes it wasn't like
he was going to kicking our people
absolutely not absolutely not I mean
this is what the Karim and strong that
historian they testify Gandhi that's
interesting about guy who's gonna grow
bread but he after he was finished
reading the Bible
Rama he was sad he was what he was in
bed why would he that I mean for the
intellectual thinking about he was known
for his nonviolent protest after why
would he be sad and why would he be
talking about I am somewhat appraising a
violent war Lord Mayor law father
doesn't make the sense it doesn't make
sense we're making sense of it all
through truth because you're talking
you're getting to know the Muslims make
the human connection we'll be right back
with more God willing double anywhere
[Applause]